-Yay!
-Hi.
-Oh, it's so great to see you.
Thank you so much for coming
back to our show.
I appreciate this.
-I'm so glad to be back,
and yeah, in this new format.
-I heard that you're in
Australia, is that correct?
-I am in Sydney, yes,
ahead of shooting "Thor."
-How -- First of all,
how is Australia?
'Cause I've never been,
and I love it,
and everyone I know
who's Australian, I love.
Everyone I've seen in movies --
I love "Muriel's Wedding."
I love everything about
Australia.
But --
It's just gorgeous, right?
-It's a really amazing
country.
I'm very -- I feel very,
very lucky to be here.
The people are amazing,
and it's a beautiful --
And, yeah.
I don't know.
You can you hear the birds,
like, singing right now?
-Yeah, that was almost on cue.
Oh, my gosh.
Whoever's helping you with
the sound effects, great job.
Let me just explain to everyone
the time difference.
Right now, it is Tuesday here
in America,
and it's Wednesday morning
where you are.
So thank you for getting up
early to do this.
-I'm in the future, yes.
-Yeah, are we going to be
all right?
-It's all going to be okay,
Jimmy.
-Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for saying that.
How are you and the family?
How are you dealing
with quarantine
and all this stuff?
-We're good.
You know, I think all of us
have had similar experiences
with kids at home during
quarantine.
It's been --
-Yeah.
-There are days when
things are great
and you're like,
I'm baking cupcakes
and we're doing crafts
and we're having a dance party.
And then there are days that
you're like,
here's a screen and I'm going to
stare at the wall.
And, you know, hope --
-Just go for it.
-Hope the day is over soon.
-Yes. Download it.
Download it.
I don't -- Yes.
Go for it. Go for it.
-Yeah.
-I don't care, yeah.
-I just kept looking at my
husband being like,
"Is it okay to have
a drink yet?"
Like, "What time is it?
Is it drink time?"
-"What time is it in America?"
-Yes.
It's Tuesday night,
let's go for it.
Can you talk about "Thor"?
I know we talked about it
a little bit
last time you were on,
and it's so secretive.
-Um, yeah, I'm playing
the Mighty Thor,
which is -- there were some
of the graphic novels
where Jane Foster becomes Thor.
And it's going to be really,
like, silly and funny and great.
We've got Taika Waititi
directing.
-Taika Waititi is
brilliantly funny.
Oh, my gosh, is he talented.
-He's wonderful.
So, I'm very excited to just
be working with --
-He has a good brain,
that guy.
Are you actually filming
or are you still prepping?
-Just prepping.
-These movies, I don't
know if people understand
the training that goes into
these things.
Did you have any idea?
I mean, are you doing these
crazy workouts and stuff?
Are you...
-I'm trying.
-It's insane.
-I've also had like --
I've had, like, months of,
like, pandemic, you know,
eating baked goods
and, like, lying in bed
and feeling sorry for myself.
-Oh, yeah.
-So it's -- I'm, like,
super tired after working out.
-Yeah.
-And during.
-And dreading before.
-While you were in quarantine,
I also saw
a couple things on Instagram.
I follow you, you're a good
follow, by the way.
There's many things you do.
One that I'm obsessed with
is your cooking videos.
I could watch you --
I could watch --
You should do a show.
I would watch every single week.
I would tune in.
I love it.
It's like, it's so -- I just,
you got a knack for it.
-Thank you.
That's so nice.
I feel like I don't really
have a lot of skill.
So I always feel like if I can
do it, anyone can do it.
And feel like sharing those
things, 'cause I know
I've gotten so many great
recipes and stuff
from Instagram, from other
people that I follow.
And it definitely
makes life easier
now that we're, like,
cooking every meal,
pretty much.
-Yeah, but no.
It think I disagree.
I think you have skill.
You know exactly --
-Thank you.
-I mean, everything is
chopped perfectly.
I mean, it's just --
It's really, honestly,
I'm obsessed.
And it's also vegetarian,
or is it vegan, even?
-Yes. Yes.
I mean, I'm vegan,
and a lot of people think
we're, like, eating alfalfa,
you know, in the corner.
You know, so I like showing...
-No.
-...that there's really,
like, delicious, varied,
easy things that you can do
at home that your kids will eat
that are plant-based.
And I've been lucky enough
to, like, learn a lot
from other people
I admire a lot.
-I love that part of,
you know,
I would say the silver lining
of all these things,
but the quarantine, you know,
you go, "Oh, my gosh,
Natalie Portman, I love her,
she's my favorite actor."
And then you get to see more
of your personal side,
and you go, "Wait,
she's a great cook
and she's interested
in cooking."
You interview chefs, and like,
they're cooking with you.
I was like --
I love that you did this.
Like, that's a gamble.
Like, you think your agent...
-Thank you.
-...would be like,
"Hey, just -- You're Thor.
We're good.
We don't need to do this stuff.
Like, just --"
You know, and I love
that you did that.
Not only that, I love
the book club, too.
-Thanks.
-How did that come about?
-Well, I love reading,
I love hearing from other people
what their recommendations are.
So I started sharing what I was
reading and what I love.
And it's great getting feedback
from people
and getting to read
alongside people
and hear what
their responses are.
And it's been a really awesome
opportunity for me too
to get to meet some of the
writers that I really love
by getting to interview them
for the book club.
It's kind of like an easy
pretext to talk to people
I really look up to.
-Yeah, I want to talk to --
There's so many other things
I want to talk to you about.
Over the summer, it was
announced that you
and some very other
accomplished women
are helping bring a brand new
women's professional soccer team
to L.A.
That's massive.
-Thank you.
-How do you get involved in
this, and how cool is that?
You're like an owner
of a soccer team?
That's nuts.
-It's so exciting.
A group of us became really
passionate about women's soccer
because we have the best players
in the world
in the United States,
in the most popular
sport in the world.
And so we got together and we
are bringing Angel City FC,
the women's soccer team for
Los Angeles, to L.A. in 2022.
And we are super excited to
just kind of celebrate
these incredible athletes.
And yeah, it's the first
female-led, female investors
of I think any
professional sport.
-And I love the name, too.
-Thanks.
-Yeah, I love it. I'm into it.